[Music]
hi Eddie so high-level feed the father
I'm going to discuss two topics which I
see there's a trouble in the Omaha he
kind of touched up on it but as the
reminder you gave us yesterday if you
remember I was speaking young zealous
bombers you know they obviously come to
the religion and you come full force and
sometimes they want to go do good and I
have no doubt most of them they have
this correct intention of doing things
the right way
but however the harshness the manners
are really lacking and unfortunately I
speak to a lot of prophets as well who
are known in the youtubes row where they
say my non-muslim friends come to me and
say is this what your part with like is
this what you go through that you just
made for example one mistake on YouTube
and then you've got this many attacks
like what advice would you give and this
question both you to these young
brothers how can they calm down a bit
and understand that yes they're trying
to enjoin good and forbid evil but there
is a time and a place to do that thing
at the right time
so what kind of advice would you give to
the youth both sisters and brothers out
there I think from like I'm not in that
much of a position I don't really know
that much about that but for me it's the
the manners and the character is so
important especially in front of the
non-muslims that you know they even
though you don't realize sometimes they
look at everything you do even the way
you dress or you know the way you talk
and you know it's so important from from
a Muslim point of view that you when you
talk to the non-muslims that oh when
you're even around if you're walking out
the room that there's a there's a sort
of demeanor and if you really you know
want to show them the Sun and you know
things like that then a lot of the time
I don't know Islam trousers ass anyway
but you have to be on your best behavior
most of the time you know even away from
when you're on your own and things like
that so you know a lot of the guys they
look at us there's a few of us Muslim
players now in a side hamdullah and when
they look at us we know that they are
not judging us but they're just checking
us out to see what what kind of people
we are really and things
and you know over time now Hyundai like
they they trust us and you know like I
said earlier we get involved with the
with the jokes and things like that and
in most cases we get involved with them
and they enjoy enjoy the company and a
lot of them will come up to us and we
didn't realize you know Muslims were you
know quite a good laugh at times and I'm
not saying like I'm a great laugh but I
know I know a lot of the guys enjoy you
know our company and I think that and
you spend so much time with them that
you have to be on your best behavior as
much as you can I think if I can add
that I appreciate what Moen has said
because he probably gets a lot of flack
from the Muslims themselves and what I
want to say look we're living in an
environment that is not an Islamic
environment you need to understand
you're living in a multicultural
multi-religious country and you're just
one of the so many that exists you need
to fulfill the rights of everyone out
there and the problem is we tend to
forget that there are different types of
people we need to talk to them in a
positive way go back to the Sunnah of
the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wa sallam
he always encouraged people it was so
positive it was such a beautiful
encouragement there was a time when some
people came to his house they found out
about his acts of worship and they
decided that they want to act or they
want to fulfill acts of worship just
like that and so they became strict on
themselves and the prophets are a lot of
Salaam heard about how one says I'm not
going to eat meat the other one says I'm
not going to touch my wife the other one
says I'm going to fast and so on and
when he addressed the situation he said
you know ma Baloo Akua mean you know
what is it with people who say this and
that he didn't say this man come here
that man you're doomed this one here you
are like this it's a weakness we have he
did not have that we have this weakness
because if there were more than those
three they would all benefit from this
common term that's being used but if if
they were if we had to use the one term
we would actually ignore the fact that
so many others would benefit and if we
were to say names a lot of the times
people become
hard to say what what did this guy say
about me I'm gonna fix him I'm gonna
show him so your intention needs to be
right knowledge and this is a
controversial statement knowledge comes
with a lot of arrogance just like money
did you hear what I said
if you don't check it you can be the
most arrogant person ever because you
know you know and you know that you know
you that you know so you look at someone
say by the way what do these guys know
nothing
they're not even Muslims that's how it
ended because why that was the knowledge
you had arrogance but when true
knowledge humbles you when you practice
according to it and you understand I
know of a certain brother he was hard he
used to call people names and take him
out of the fold and so on and so forth a
lot tested him with his own children
leaving the fold of Islam and then I
happened to chat with him and I told him
brother you so hard and so he said I've
learned my lesson
I was pointing at everyone else and
Allah tested me in my own home so this
is the challenge this is what Allah
probably made him go through this to
realize that he's being too hard on
everyone else
the Perron says to Muhammad SAW Allah
Allah Allah says well Kunta fallen
relieve al qalbi land [ __ ] bloomin
Holika you know if you were hard harsh
hard-hearted and you had to be hard in
your wording and in the way you dealt
with them they would have dispersed from
around you they would disperse so this
goes to show today we need a lot of
convincing we need to talk to people
it's no longer like a long time ago is
to say fulfill your salah they said ok
ok Allah or no no it's no longer like
that now fulfill your Salah you can
expect a child to say why what do I have
in it that's what's happening you can't
just slap them like I told you to slap
me no we still belong to the previous
generation we will accept the slap but
they won't they won't so this is why we
need to be humble I believe there is
great damage when people become a little
bit popular and they use that popularity
to attack rather than to build remember
this I mean look at what's happening
across the world at the moment we're
struggling because people prefer to
destroy rather than to build and and
they justify it no matter what and I
always say people say
what about these killings I say we are
against all killings no matter who is
perpetrating them it's dangerous it's
detrimental we prefer to build to
resolve the matter to solve it I'd
rather sit with you I'd rather try to do
things and people say no ways you don't
know what you're talking about
be consistent continue in the right path
don't lose hope when you know be focused
and like I was telling you yesterday and
a few of the brothers who we were
talking to today it's become very
difficult to remain on the moderate path
it's very easy because we are being
bombarded from two extremes to actually
fall when you're doing something right
and you on the moderate path when I say
moderate path I don't mean you've given
up your deem no I mean the way you treat
others and the way you carry yourself
the way you look at others how you want
to present the Deen to them so there are
people who bash and they tell you you're
so wrong until you bash you've got a
bath just like we do and if you just
remain focused ignore ignore ignore it's
so difficult to be on this middle path
because on the other hand they're people
who will also call you names while
you're on the middle path to sway you
that way and my advice neither sway this
way nor that way remain on the path
remain focused keep on giving people
this hope and inshallah you will see the
result by the will of allah subhanahu
wata'ala look at these faces look at
these beautiful people why do you think
they're here all of them are here to be
inspired to get a good word to feel like
allah loves them as they walk out of
here to feel good imagine if we had to
come here and make them feel like they
were already going to hell subhanAllah
you know you guys doomed that's it every
one of you watch out you're gonna go how
I should I even say that I prefer
especially in this world to choose the
prophetic method of giving people hope
and yes there is a time when warnings do
come through if you notice sometimes
when I would when I where did I see who
I'm talking to and I say brothers and
sisters those who do good will go to
paradise and then when I see who I'm
talking to a group of youngsters and so
on and I say and those who don't they
will go elsewhere you heard me say that
what does elsewhere refer to here guys
can someone say it Wow did you hear the
little
a small young boy mashallah saying it
refers to Hellfire
did I say Hellfire I didn't he
understood what I said here we are we
got it in a beautiful way but we hit it
exactly where it's supposed to be I
don't need to say ban Hellfire you know
it's gonna it's there but hang on there
is a place and the time to say it that
way first you need to win the people you
need to understand that the people are
you know what is keeping them on the
demon as a famous person or anyone who's
popular it's easy for you to sit behind
the screen to sit behind the camera no
one knows what exactly you go through in
your life and you just bombarding
everybody you don't know what they are
going through in their lives I tell you
one thing brother Ali my travels across
the globe have softened me in a big way
because I've seen people from different
walks of life trying to please Allah and
I've realized those who haven't traveled
and seen and you know witnessed what
everyone is doing sometimes they don't
appreciate the circumstances surrounding
the person's you know life and they
start saying statements that are very
very hurtful so if you choose beautiful
words inshallah you will be able to
touch people in a much much better way
may Allah forgive me for taking so long
to respond
shoot shoot shoot
hey give me one thanks Arnie subscribe